I wrestled for WWE for so long and like
I've been able to
tell my body to do something and it'll
do it you know and I feel like I was so
helpless in that moment that I couldn't
control this and it was so frustrating
because I was like there's nothing you
can do so after the miscarriage we
started trying again and nothing was
happening I worked with the fertility
doctor with her name was the egg
Whisperer we did a few things before it
led to IVF because I definitely like
I wanted to try naturally I wanted it to
happen naturally and Joe has super sperm
so
which is a fact we know he does you know
sorry babe how to chalk you up there
that's something like that don't like
that
WWE fans were used to seeing Barbie's
body slams
chokeholds and dangerous cartwheels
before she retired from wrestling
full-time in 2012. now Barbie and
husband Joe Koba who's a bodybuilder
just celebrated their two-year wedding
anniversary and their Miracle babies are
due around September 5th I have to say
too like I mean pregnancy looks amazing
wears it very well
okay now I want to go back to the embryo
day because there's a special story
behind it yes when we were talking about
with Dr Amy when the day was going to be
when we were going to implant the
embryos and one of the dates was going
to be my dad's birthday
and you know my my dad passed away five
years ago of a rare brain cancer and
you know
I just feel like in these little moments
of like he's with me today and it's
really significant that that was his
birthday that that was the day
that my babies were going to be born you
know what I mean and it's just yeah it's
just the most to me and I felt him in
that room I felt him like holding my
other hand Joe was holding you know and
it was just it couldn't have been a more
perfect I just feel like everything
happens for a reason and I feel like
everything that we went through was
meant to happen and the way it is to
have twins and you know what would your
dad say seeing you become a mama I had
thought about this the other day I'm
gonna cry
um I was driving and I just was like you
know he would just be calling and he
would just be so excited be calling
every day just like I can't wait to hold
my until my grandchildren and just he
would just be the most amazing
grandfather he would be so proud you
strike me as someone who'd be like you
need your feet rubbed I got you you need
to cry on my shoulder I got you I'm glad
I give that impression
is that how he is too like just from
like day by day as you are physically
growing and experiencing new things it's
probably like the craving like I'll be
like babe I really I want donuts and
he'll be like babe and then I'll be like
it's fine and then the donuts
thank you
do you know what you're having you're
not only blessed with one Miracle but
you have two
kids we do know we put in you know two
embryos of of our the sex of our choice
and yeah you guys will find out soon is
your wardrobe any tea
I don't think he's looking at me he's
like
I just know better and so I thought she
was wearing and I thought I would you
know do my best that's it no tease
nothing
we still have some time left so what is
your birth plan have you talked about it
yet yeah okay yeah I took a birthing
class like a birthing Zoom
um I want I'm gonna bring a doula into
the hospital just because I feel like I
don't want him stressing and like having
to tell doctors my birth plan like I
just want him to be in the moment
holding my hand I don't need him like
handing out the okay she wants this and
this and this I so I'm like let me bring
a doula in she'll be the advocate for
for what I want to share that moment
together I want Joe to pull the babies
out oh
that's special come on
on stuff like that I don't even know if
I have a decision she just said pull the
babies out I said okay I feel like
[Music]
there he is like oh wow when you do
think of those future moments you think
of being in the hospital room together
when you think of that day that special
day where your bundles the plural of Joy
come into this world what comes to mind
just the overall
thoughts on that special day
go ahead honey
he was like let me hear were you upset
um
I'm just so looking forward to just the
second they come out just having them
both on my chest just like hearing their
cries and then you know hopefully they
won't cry after they're on me but just
having that moment and having Joe be
right next to me and hopefully have one
of them on his chest too and we're just
like in that moment where we're just
like this is heaven this is what we've
you know wanted for so long and it's
here and just like picturing that moment
of our babies and our arms it was just
like I just can't wait I just like I
want them here now what does that mean
to you to know that you are helping
other people in some of the most
difficult moments of their life just by
sharing your own story it means so much
it really does like and I and I really
when I started my IVF journey I was like
I want to be open about that too because
I feel like women can relate to that
because I feel like it's such a it's not
a Spoke people women a lot of times
don't talk about it it's looked at like
it's looked down upon like oh my I I
have to resort to IVF because I can't
get pregnant and like I don't want
people to know that I want people to
think I'm like perfect and everything is
great and I just was like let me take
women Along on this journey with me
that's why I worked with the fertility
doctor that I work with and she's we did
a documentary on um and she followed you
know six other women and there are
different stories and so it was really
really just amazing to be able to to
talk about it and have women relate to
you have you given thought to work or is
it right now no like are you ready to be
back in the ring anytime in the future
or you know it was cool because
WrestleMania was here obviously and I
got to bring Joe backstage and I got him
you know he got to meet all my
colleagues and everybody and it was so
cool and everybody was so sweet and they
were so excited
um to see me pregnant and but the good
thing is and the doors always open there
and we have it I have a great
relationship with everybody there and
it's a dream of mine for my kids to see
me in the ring to get inducted into the
Hall of Fame to see me wrestle one more
time like that is literally like my
Ultimate Dream to be like that's my mom
what would you say if your children
wanted to follow and Mama's footsteps
you know you know what if that's
something that they're interested in
then you know it's our job to facilitate
that and be as supportive as as we
possibly can so the big question would
be like do your names sound great on the
PA system entering the ring
they do
what would you say about maybe cameras
following you two and the babies around
like would you ever do a show and I
talked about that we talked about it the
other day and I meet
but he's been I mean the last four years
like he's just been such a trooper
through
all the things
[Music]